Today is one of those nights.
We got take out again, and we couldn't decide,
so we got. I. She.
She couldn't decide. I couldn't decide.
I could decide. I'm a Libra.
That's just what I do. Look how they twisted their mind.
No. Very considerate of them,
Ben.
What's this? Thank you.
Ground pork, extra noodles,
ramen.
What's this? I think it's your tempura.
Oh, nice.
I love how everything comes separate.
Very good. Are you gonna microwave?
Um, most likely, yeah.
This is mine. Food needs to be piping hot in order for it to be good.
We're also watching house of Dragons.
I've gotten lucky into it.
He never watched game of Thrones.
I'm obsessed with wagamamas,
and they never had a Texas location.
When I was pregnant and craving it so bad,
I got these bao buns with eggplant and mushrooms.
These are so insanely good.
And then I've never had Wagamama's gyoza before,
but I got some pork gyoza.
Where's my broth?
But it's in. But it's not brothy enough.
No, they see mine.
Mine came in separate.
They thought about this. Wagamama.
Why is there a wilted salad in my soup?
This is why I cook my own food,
but this is what I get. I get.
I don't know which number it is,
but it's two tablespoons of broth.
Oh, my.
How I was so excited for the broth.
There's always something wrong in my.
I had a feeling that that might happen.
I love your little wet paper towels.
So I also got us Wingstop
because also
I just wanted some wings to put inside what? I wanted
the sauce on the side. Original, hot.
What's this? Ranch.
This is ranch.
First of all, ranch is gross. So you're gross
without seasoning? I just get lemon pepper.
That is the seasoning. Well, yeah,
I get them with lemon pepper seasoning,
but not sauce. Also,
lucky and I have just been watching skits of ourselves on TikTok.
Actually hilarious. There's this one guy.
What videos did you do? Yeah,
an inhaler and then the.
Then he did, like,
a sunscreen video. Also,
who's following all this drama that's going on?
Cause I'm the man, you understand?
This feels illegal. Hmm.
Double noodle.
This is what it looks like without spilling.
Thank you.
This feels like a really random food haul,
but we're gonna go watch house of Dragons and enjoy our food.